so we went from seven pieces of content
a week i did three on youtube and i just
repurposed the same three on a podcast
to 80 80 content pieces a week and so
this is what happened in those six
months we added 300 000 subscribers on
youtube 350 000 on tick tock 150 000
buyers on amazon for the book 350 000
followers
on instagram 100 000 on twitter and 400
000 downloads a month on the podcast and
so here's the how and so this is the
content creation model
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres the host of the
show where we want to help you build
your influence on youtube and then turn
that influence into a high impact and
high profit online business we want to
welcome you if you are brand new to the
show and also welcome back to all of our
returning listeners if you've not yet
subscribed wherever you receive this
content i want to encourage you to do
that because we deliver a brand new
episode every single tuesday so hit the
subscribe button i don't know why i'm
holding up a like sign but hit the
subscribe button on youtube or wherever
you like to listen to your podcast well
today's video is brought to you by a
brand new free resource that we want to
get in your hands you can go to 21
21videotips.com where you can actually
get information just like this like
we're doing here on the podcast but even
more we've got 21 video marketing tips
from people like patrickbetdavid vanessa
lau pat flynn and the person on our
podcast today is alex hermosi we've got
more tips for you from alex inside of
our 21 videotips.com
you can get some of the top marketing
secrets right now and they are sharing
their best kept business building
secrets inside of this resource for you
we also have a downloadable guide that
goes along with this free resource so
that you can get massive impact today
with these video secrets so go to
21videotips.com
to get that free resource right now well
today i am giddy because one of the on
the rise influencers or entrepreneurs
who is actually teaching what he's done
alex or mozy is on today's podcast we're
going to be doing a two-part series with
alex for you here on the show and today
we're talking all about how he was able
to grow to over 1 million followers in
less than six months
why he decided to go in on content
marketing and what the shift was for him
as an entrepreneur and
how he did it and how he built a team
around it now if you've not heard of
alex hermozy yet from acquisition.com
let me just tell you a little bit about
who this entrepreneur is alex ramose is
a first generation iranian american
entrepreneur investor philanthropist and
the founder of acquisition.com that's a
portfolio company that does about 100
million dollars a year he's most known
in the online space for his expertise in
customer acquisition and monetization
through his experience in scaling
companies quickly alex is one of the
fastest growing entrepreneurs on social
media right now and his youtube channel
has over 26 million views where he helps
entrepreneurs learn how to get more
customers he's also the best-selling
author of the book 100 million dollar
offer and he's the guest on today's show
so grab your pen and paper lean into
today's episode with alex hermosie
[Music]
so i was telling showing backstage i
said my promise to you is that this will
be the worst presentation you have ever
heard the best presentation you've ever
heard or somewhere in between so that is
my promise uh for you guys today so
let's
kick some butt cool let me see it's my
oh i'm gonna go back one there we go
okay so i'll just kind of share with you
some of the things that i've learned
over the last six months so how i built
a million plus organic following in the
last six months cool
good news is if you can do it like this
anybody can do it all right
so um just transparency on this like i
built all my companies off paid ads
affiliates cold outbound teams or
referrals and that is usually what i'm
asked to speak about i have never built
an organic brand this is my first time
so
i just like to get those disclaimers out
ahead of time and so what i have to
share may not work for everyone or in
fact be true at all
uh
but it worked for me this time so that's
what i'm going to share okay so just
take everything with a gigantic grain of
salt that i say all right
because a lot of you guys are probably
better at this stuff than i am so that's
probably you guys here there's me on the
side
watching you guys be much better than me
at video and so without uh further ado
one million fans six months in 60
minutes or less
so uh this morning i i don't know if you
guys do this but like morning of i redo
what's up cold um i redo everything
again because i'm like oh this is i have
to redo it all uh and so i broke it into
three sections to make more sense so
section one is why did i do this to
begin with
and why you might think it's a good idea
too uh two what and how and how much
like what do we do to actually create
that
and then third is observations because i
had no other better heading for it
than that so that's what it is okay so
let's rock and roll so quick backstory
i'm gonna go through this as fast as
possible this is me when i started my
business career sleep on the floor i
signed my first lease slept on that
floor for the first nine months was able
to uh get it to that picture on the left
in a year then i opened a new location
every six months after that
and then over the next 18 months i met
layla and we did gym turnarounds so we
basically fly
from place to place to place and fill
gyms up and that it was a hands-on sales
model i had at our peak eight sales guy
turn around eight gyms every month
that became tenuous
logistically and we're like i wonder if
there's a better way and so from there
we packaged our ip for a better gym
model into a licensing business and so
we were able to grow
jim launch which was a b2b business to
two and a half million bucks a month
prestige to 1.7 a month which is b to b
to c that was an affiliate based
business and it was weight loss and
supplements so e-commerce then we scaled
ln to 1.6 million a month which was b to
b to c
um and we just recently sold that for
46.2 and we just sold that one last year
as well which i'm not allowed to say the
number but there you go um and then we
started acquisition.com which right now
does about 13 million a month
which is cool
and
oh
i appreciate it um so
that sounded weird um so right now we
grow 3 million plus internet businesses
into 30 million plus sellable businesses
that's kind of what we do now and so
hopefully you're probably asking this
question which is like what does this
have to do with growing video or growing
with video
[Applause]
but i started making video content with
three goals so number one was to attract
uh internet business owners doing three
million dollars or more who align with
our values uh number two is to help all
businesses below our minimum deal size
to just grow to the deal size that was
kind of the idea like how do i just get
everybody's at a million to three
million or 100k to three million
whatever just get everybody up above
that level so we can hopefully work with
them um and then three to create a place
where i could document you the best
practices of building world-class
companies from my experience and like
we're not
the elon musks and the basos and and all
that but
i wish that those guys had documented
what they had done like how cool would
it have been to see like the vlog of
amazon in 1996 right how sick would that
have been and like every day is like yup
almost lost the company today like
six months later almost lost the company
again
i thought that would have been awesome
so i thought you know i didn't i did a
really poor job of documenting
everything up to this point and so i was
really committed to like all right for
this next phase
i really want to do a better job of it
so that's the idea all right oops
and uh ironically when we started doing
that lo and behold business is doing 3
million or more
started reaching out to us which was
awesome right success so i guess this
might have something to do with video
but believe me when i say that no one is
surprised
as me about this kind of organic stuff
in general because i've never done it
before so we're on this ride together
all right so here's the goal for the
presentation give you a few lessons that
i've learned to take you from wherever
you are
to a little closer to wherever you want
to go
with this presentation i'm so good at
content there's the little man okay
great so disclaimer again never done
this i also didn't want to be famous or
known for a very long time there's me
saying i want to be rich not famous
but several experiences changed my mind
so i'll walk you through this really
quickly so when kylie do you remember
this when kylie was announced that she
was a billionaire
well that's what i felt like that day
i was like what am i doing wrong
and then the rock you know killing it
and then boom he's got a two billion
dollar plus uh tequila brand that he was
able to launch off his organic audience
conor mcgregor 600 million with proper
12 has probably grown by since now huda
now is a billion dollar brand
and so i can be a little slow sometimes
but i could kind of read the writing on
the wall
uh so there's the writing on the wall
but i didn't want to build an e-commerce
brand because all those were ecommerce
physical products brands and i was like
that's not my vibe i already did that
once it's not like it's not my favorite
of the businesses that we've done so i
still kind of like dragged my feet a
little bit and that's when i heard this
guy nomad capitalist who like teaches
people to not be u.s citizens that's not
the point but um
so you can not pay taxes but anyways um
that's when i heard a podcast with this
guy and he was like oh yeah i get about
3 000 applications a month i was like
holy cannoli i was like well if i had 3
000 applications a month i would make at
least one dollar if that were my life
and so
i realized it could work for b2b
not just e-commerce stuff i was like
that's neat and then i heard neil patel
was doing 100 million bucks a year doing
b2b agency services all off inbound
i was like okay
this might make sense and so again i
still was like all right so it does work
for b2b organic stuff works but i still
didn't really want to be famous that was
not my vibe
and so i met up with dear friends of
ours lisa and dean graciosi
and we had a conversation that was kind
of last straw here so i was like dude
being famous sounds terrible he was just
telling us about how like somebody like
showed up his house and threatened his
kids and i was like that sounds [ __ ]
awful like why
no no thank you i'm good i'll just pass
on grass and so
he's like if getting harassed and
attacked is the price i have to pay for
the
it's supposed to say impact
[Laughter]
that was perfect um
for the impact that i want to have then
i'd pay that price every time which
totally takes away from the impact of
that message um
but
i was like he's right you know what i
mean like he said if if if that's the
price i have to pay to make the impact i
want to have and i pay that price every
time i was like
all right i need to i need to stop being
all right
so
18 months ago i started a youtube
channel
some of you guys may have anybody seen
this the youtube channel
moseynation
and so i built two expensive studios to
launch this thing um i started making
three videos a week
side note important lesson that i
learned on a vacation
that really one did better than my
really fancy one which then taught me
that
what's inside the content matters more
than the wrapper so for anybody who's
like worried about getting started about
making it look right
i don't think it matters
i mean i think it matters a little bit
but it's 80 20. so focus on the 80.
well i hope you are enjoying today's
session and i wanted to let you know
that if you are loving content like this
then you definitely need to go to 21
videotips.com
where you can actually get 21 more video
marketing tips just like this from
industry experts like patrickbetdavid
vanessa lau pat flynn and alex hermozy
and so many amazing video marketers of
our day they're sharing their best kept
business building secrets inside of this
master class and free downloadable guide
so just head over to
21videotips.com to get instant access
for free and learn how you can level up
your business and brand that's
21videotips.com
now let's get back into today's content
all right and so i continued my very
steady growth
for
for
that period of time which is great
recommend
um but you know in the first 12 months
we went from 600 to 70 000 subscriber
which was cool
and so things were going smoothly until
one day i had to chat with grant cardone
about branding and it reminded me that
all the lessons that i learned in
business apply to all this organic stuff
and so i was on this call with him and i
have the full video on my youtube
channel if you want to check it out um
yeah
he was like bro
i'm not even gonna try
he was like bro pull up your instagram i
was like okay he's like pull up my
instagram he's like i got ten times the
content is you ten times he's like bro
it's volume bro volume
and um
i was like that's deep
um
and so i was like you know i should
probably do more uh which is a lesson
that i have learned over and over and
over again in business and i'll tell you
a more story about later uh but like so
many times we're doing the right stuff
we're just doing way
way too little of it
like i'll tell you a quick story which
is not on this presentation but when i
started my first gym i was told that i
should put flyers out and so i went uh
you know i'm like really you know full
of vinegar i'm gonna go do it so
the business owner told me had was more
successful me et cetera and so i went i
put the flyers out and then
like nothing really happened so i met
back up with him a few weeks later and
he was like hey how the flyers work and
i was like uh
you know i got one guy who called me and
said i picked up his car
um
that was it he's like what was your test
size
i was like hm
uh
i was like well i mean i i put 300 out
and he was like
dude our test side is 5 000.
he's like that's what we test with he's
like and then we do 5000 a day
i was like oh
noted
and so it was just a really good lesson
and that happens with phone calls like
yeah i'm doing i'm going to start doing
cold calls you make 10 calls every three
days when you're feeling motivated
rather than doing 200 aisles every day
like it's clockwork before lunch you
know i mean the level of effort
difference is not like 2x or 4x it's
like 50x it's a lot bigger and most
people dramatically underestimate the
amount of volume and effort that is
required to get to where you want to go
like dramatically and so those i've so
many lessons that this repeated and i
was taught yet again in a different
sphere that i'm not
familiar with that this was true i'm
also wearing the same shirt
so i decided to take his advice and
dramatically increase the amount of
content that we created and how many
places we displayed it right and so
before i tell you um who wants to guess
how many pieces of content we started
putting out weekly after that call
25
10 000 less than that i would be so much
more famous if i put 10 000 out what was
that 100 good good guess so we went from
seven pieces of content a week i did
three on youtube and i just repurposed
the same three on a podcast um to 80 80
content pieces a week
and for scale if you remember the first
line that i showed you way before the
top of that is that purple line
from the first graph i showed you
and so
pretty pretty cool and so this is what
happened in those six months we added
300 000 subscribers on youtube 7 000
followers on instagram still haven't
really cracked that one uh 350 000 on
tick tock 150 000 buyers which is cool
uh on amazon for the book uh 350 000
followers on instagram 100 000 on
uh twitter and 400 000 downloads a month
on the podcast
cool
right so basically a hundred a million
person
audience uh within that six months and
because i'm more of a business guy than
i am a quote influencer creator uh this
is what i cared about so the net traffic
result for us was web traffic went from
basically non-existent to about a
hundred thousand uh unique clicks a
month to the site just organically
pretty cool
uh number two is the subscribers i told
you before
and then this is one that's really cool
for who here runs paid ads can i get a
okay some of you cool so this this will
resonate with you
so in the businesses that i had at a 25
cpm we were getting two million dollars
a month in exposure for free
not only not free we're getting paid to
do it
crazy like i'm i'm beside myself still
because i think it's insane so the fact
that this opportunity exists right now
is literal insanity to me like we're
getting paid now to market
like what a world right
and so the business result from that is
that we get about 400 companies a month
that apply for acquisition.com uh so we
can help them scale um and in that time
period we grew from 7 million a month to
13 million a month
and disclaimer on that is that part of
that was just the the companies
themselves grew it wasn't like new
companies um
but still a lot in six months and so if
you're anything like me you're probably
thinking well that's really great for
you alex but what about me which is why
i made section two
which is how and how much all right so
here's where you come in all right so
let's start with how much so just a
reminder here in terms of time i'm not
like a creator full time so it's like 93
7 is probably the amount of time that i
allocate towards this and so money-wise
this costs me 20 000 a month to do all
right you can scale this down however
you want i also don't have a tremendous
amount of time that i allocate towards
it so i have to compensate with that
with money you could probably do this on
your own i just i this is how i do it
so we have a twitter editor a youtube
editor a linkedin editor a podcast
editor and an ign tick tock editor all
right um and there's two of us so times
two so it's actually 40 000 a month for
the both of us okay the amount of time
that it takes me is two days per month
and four hours per week
uh and that is that is what i dedicate
towards this
and so quick recap i have a daily mind
dump which i'll show you how i do it in
a second because we're going to show you
i'm going to show you the whole model um
i do a weekly twitter review it takes me
like four hours because twitter's
actually really important to how i do
all this stuff which i'll explain later
and if you guys aren't on twitter
actually it's my favorite platform but
um
we do one day a month of recording and
then uh for shorts and then one day a
month uh it's usually like a half day
i'll do like four to eight youtube
videos the ones that are direct to
camera and that's it that's the that's
the jam so that's the how much that's
what that's my investment that's my cost
to do this and so here's the how
and so this is the content creation
model all right that's the big visual
and those are the bold bullets fantastic
let's start with the first one
so test record inject contextualize
distribute
so the old way that i used to do content
was i would just have this ongoing email
thread to myself i know you guys have
like notes or like a chain to yourself
because you probably get ideas you're in
a conversation i should make a piece of
content on that right and then you email
it yourself that's how i did it for a
long time
and the new way
is the twitter way which is uh being
blocked by the thing because it
formatted weird but uh i post all of
those ideas as tweets on twitter rather
than just sending them to myself and so
all of a sudden what used to be my inbox
is actually just my like tweet thread
all right and so i tweet about five
times a day ish
and the nice thing is that twitter is a
very forgiving
platform so it's just like stream of
consciousness and it takes notes you
don't have to pick vid you know videos
or captions or i like it because it's
just thoughts like that's i love twitter
so much for that reason and so i'll post
this stuff and i'll be like okay those
are the ones that people thought were
interesting
and then the threads become long format
and the shorts become short format or
the tweets become short format pretty
simple
step one everyone following with me so
long yeah
oh man
and we feel like they could do that
all right doable yes
second step is recording right why am i
doing both
i realized this because you're like why
you do short stuff um i was kind of
against shorts and then i realized that
i've never actually consumed anything
from garyvee that's long
but i like garyvee a lot i was like oh
well i guess that work so
that's why i do both
right and so i think it's a width and
depth thing i think the shorts give you
a lot of breath i think the longs give
you a lot of depth right
and so there's a visual that i put
together that took me too long to say
that same thing great
so this is everything that i know about
about how to make content that quote
goes viral i watched a long like
interview with mr beast my big practice
of trying to learn stuff is go to the
person who's the best at it and listen
to them because they've already
reorganized the information for you hack
um and so he's like listen all these
guys make this all compliment their tags
and the hashtags and if any of you guys
saw that this is not me offending you i
have no idea what i'm talking about
remember big grain of salt um but he
said it's just ctr times watch time
that's it you got to get people to click
you got to get people to watch
i was like okay that makes sense he's
like and that's what youtube wants they
want people to be interested in the
content to get the click and then make
sure that the content fulfills the
promise of the thumbnail
cool i was like i can do that and so
this is the general format that i've
used for the longs which is like a
hooker a question that i'm answering
usually a story that's relevant to
answer the question a framework that
i've applied to repeat that process and
then an explanation of why i think it
works that's it and if i want to make
longer stuff it's just that process with
multiple stories repeating that over and
over again the shorts is a hooker
question a hammer which for me is my
tweet
i put the tweet as the next thing i say
because i already know it converts
um and then i have an example and an
explanation
that's about it that's
alex's million-dollar thing there we go
fantastic and so this is an example so
it's like 20 ways to guarantee poverty
or 28 ways to stay poor right so i made
this thread got a lot of shares cool 28
rules reprogramming to be rich in 22
minutes so i have to change the the you
know the headline and stuff but the
content was identical i just did it in a
video right and then the short ones that
do well it's like all right overheard
from an abc blah blah authenticity is
just a fancy word
boom i just make a short version of the
same thing just saying the tweet this
makes sense
okay cool and then i upload it
fancy so far
all right ta-da
next one is inject so uh we grew the the
podcast actually recently from like 20
000
a month to 400 000 a month and a big
part of that was just having call to
actions um sounds really dumb but i
wasn't doing it so
do it
and so the way that we did it was we
recorded two versions of each of the
call to action so like call to actions
to other channels lead medics share a
tag if you have a lower ticket product i
don't but like or you know for me i just
have a book it's 99 cents um you know
leave a review uh if you want to ask for
clients or you know send a question or
there's my book their grand slam offer
so i would just record two different
ctas for that
and then i just inject them into the
content so this is what it might look
like see it's like you have your cta1
content mid-roll content uh end-off does
that make sense so we started doing that
with the podcast and it started to grow
a lot and now we're actually doing it in
the rest of the forms of content so
you'll see that from me uh because this
has been working uh so this is me doing
this walking the talk all right the
point directions etc okay contextualize
so anyone seen this one before everyone
see this like me that went viral
so it's like everybody kind of appears
somewhat differently even though it's
the same person depending on the setting
that you're in right on facebook you
look a certain way linkedin you look a
certain way tinder look a certain way um
i had a sales guy who uh was on t this
is not relevant at all um was on tinder
and uh and he would close every one of
his dates uh on buying our supplements
um
so that he could get he was like it
always covered dinner um
savage anyways um
just you know shooter's gotta shoot okay
so
so you have to make the stuff contextual
and so this is what we do so this is the
same video right it's that same uh navy
seal video i made earlier right so
that's a real that's a tick tock and
then that's the youtube short so it's
the same thing you just you just make it
match the platform same way you would
make your facebook look different than
your instagram look different than your
linkedin etc as long as you just make it
contextual i think it does a lot better
because have you guys seen people just
like take literally the exact same thing
and post it on the wrong platform
i just think it just hurts it and it's
just not that much effort to make it
contextual
all right last one distribute
then we distribute them all right so we
went from seven times a week to 80 times
a week in distribution that was the
result over that six month period
which was a lot of growth awesome
and so we 10x the inputs and we got 10x
the outputs
surprising
right
so who here would like 10 times the
output
well then you can just 10x the input
all right
good talk
um
so
quick recap
all right content creation model
test
first thing you do
make your brain dump into something
that's actually generating content so
this this is net zero time for me i was
doing it and i just started doing it
publicly
number two is that once i have the stuff
that's winning i record it i record the
threads as long as i record the tweets
as shorts
from there the team injects the call to
action so that i can direct the traffic
whatever way i want to direct it right
four and big one on this last injection
thing like
if you don't do this because i wasn't it
you you get all of these impressions and
like eyeballs and stuff and you'll get
followers but like you don't drive a
result
um which again sounds silly that i
wasn't doing this but i told you the
beginning you guys are better than i am
at this
number four was contextualize it i just
think it works a lot better
and then finally you cut it and increase
the volume
well that is part one of our two-part
series here on the show with alex
hermozy we're going to be diving deeper
into his observations that third step
that he talked about in today's episode
and that will be coming out very soon so
make sure you are locked in here on the
show so that you can get access to that
second part and all the things that alex
learned from figuring out how to go all
in with his content creation now every
single week we love to bring one of our
think fam members here on the show and
say thank you for rating and review this
podcast when you do that over on apple
podcast it helps other entrepreneurs and
content creators just like you see that
this show is for them so i want to thank
today's reviewer which is i fun chris
channel chris says the think media
podcast review i learned a lot on
youtube and you're helping me out thanks
for the help to the youtube creators
well thank you so much chris for being
one of our listeners and for taking the
time to rate and review the show it
means the world to us now if you've not
left a comment down below on youtube i'm
gonna encourage you to share your aha
moment from this episode i love to be
able to go through read your comments
and see the value that you're getting
from what we're doing here on the
podcast so leave your aha moment down
below i'd love to read it and thank you
so much for being a part of what we're
doing part two of this series will be
coming out shortly so make sure you're
locked in and we'll catch you in the
next episode bye
[Music]
you